there is johnny cueto
ready to go he's always entertaining
isn't he he is uh his start number 307
for cueto in his career 40 games over
500 2-1 this year with the 478 prime el
topia is in the batter's box and this is
hit up the middle crawford's going to
try to cut it off he spins it through
got him and that's how this game gets
started
as crawford ends up in shallow right
field a fabulous play by brandon
crawford against a speedy runner now
it's kevin pilar the rockies
center fielder this is line to center
field he's going to get down and the uh
former giant with a knock against san
francisco with one out he's aboard for
charlie blackmon slashes one to left
field and that's gonna drop in front of
dickerson for a base hit so with one out
the rockies go back to back with singles
to the outfield and trevor story hitting
in the cleanup spot we'll try and give
the rockies an early advantage against
cueto now there's a called strike three
in the outside corner with a fastball
great pitch by cueto right on the corner
so the rockies will need a two out hit
from the guy who's been delivering the
rbi hits here in september josh fuentes
fuentes hits it over crawford's head
into left field for a base hit josh
fawentes does it again
a two-out rbi single and the rockies
take a one to nothing lead here comes
ryan mcmahon mcmahon rips it to right
and that's gonna bang off the wall
blackman will score the rockies lead it
two to nothing so not a good first
inning for cueto two runs in four hits
there's a ground ball to short right to
crawford knight charges it throws over
the first
and the inning is over on the hill
tonight for the rockies will be the
right-handed veteran he's in his fourth
year it's ermann marquez 61 230 pounder
in the air to left field down the line
still in fair ground fighting the wind a
little bit rymel tapia makes the play
and
that's out number one here comes brandon
bell this is luke till shallow left
toffee at closing speed gets there two
gone two now nobody on donovan solano
comes up now swing line drive into
center field base hit and he smoked that
one 105 miles an hour off the bat of
donovan solano here comes darren ruff
now breaking ball bounced towards third
mcmahon charges runs on to the infield
grass throws to fuentes and that takes
care of the inning kevin palar leads off
against plato this ball crushed high and
deep left field and
gone kevin pilar
hurting his old team here in the third
three nothing colorado back-to-back two
out singles for the giants and donovan
solano has a chance to get the giants on
the board swinging a ground ball to
guess who garrett hampson has a quick
throw over to first marquez works out of
the testy spot in the third the rockies
have a runner at third with only one
away for tapia infield in
and a bulk was called
a bark was called and the rockies will
get their fourth run hillyard comes home
you know what i mean he does that all
the time but in their mind it was a
start stop by definition of the rule it
is a bond colorado already leading four
nothing they've got a chance here to
break it open bases full of rockies
elias diaz the hitter hit towards left
field going back dickerson off his glove
it's gonna score a pair of runs and
elias diaz with a long single makes it
six-nothing rockies that will be the end
of the night for johnny cueto so here's
hampton this ball lined to left field
it'll get down for a base hit rbi's
single by garrett hampson
seven nothing rockies can ocelano run is
it second and third two down and he
swings and it's a ground ball into right
field of base head wasabi comes in to
score and the giants are on the board oh
and here comes darren ruff slowly hit
bare hand throw to first in time wow
and not nolan over there but it looked a
whole lot like 28 wonderful play by
mcmahon and here's alex dickerson nice
night for alex two for three including a
double
two of the five giants hit so far
dickerson drives one out toward right
center field this one is crushed and it
is gone up into the colorado bullpens
alex dickerson goes deep
for the first time as a dad
his ninth home run of the year it's
seven to two tyler kindly on the pitch
for colorado it's the last chance for
the giants bottom of the ninth the
giants trail the rockies seven to two
alex dickerson has had a single a double
and a homer in this game a chance for
him to hit for the cycle if he got a
triple here look out he drilled him
man he tried to throw that cutter or
hard slide or whatever it is 90 miles an
hour did he go too far he did that
strike three and that's the ball game